the haunted house pop-up shop worked
incredibly well better than I could have
ever hoped but there's more that we
could do what is a pop-up shop really
about and its base level a pop-up shop
is a clothing store that pops up out of
nowhere that's how it all started way
back in the early 80s or 90s or whatever
the hell it actually first started I
don't know when but it did at some point
some mr. pop up decided that it was time
to go sell clothes on the corner and
people went bananas for people went
apeshit but I can do it one better
because if there's one thing that people
said about me it's that I have no sense
of style no sense of fashion nothing
about me screams that I plan to anything
that I did today any way we can make a
pop-up shop and we can make a pop-up
shop better than everybody else did
because we got a fan what does a pop-up
shop need and what do I need to get rid
of clothes it's an anagram clothes lose
original taste hence everything sale
makes sense okay cool and number two you
need pop-up people only purchase unsold
products makes sense and then number
three I need to let go let's emotionally
traumatize get out
we're gonna bring my clothes to the
office here's some of my old clothes and
the reason I'm doing my old clothes
because I'm not gonna go out and buy
clothes and try to resell it this is
vintage this has history this is a
classic I want to let go of it oh these
are the pants from the lonely instincts
oh oh no these are the Bulge pants ah
disco discomfort mmm I did not wash that
obvious was from the deer the deer man
video Oh
oh man hmm help me well don't you dare
not even a little bit it took me years
to get this back don't it is what it is
I got this shirt for five dollars at
Walmart
oh this is oh these are the lonely
instinct pants oh hell yeah
down Oh lonely instinct indeed I've lost
weight since I last wore this fits even
better now no no no
no no I think we taught that no way in
hell I'm giving away an elusive shirt I
think that's a good pile good anyway
all right okay so what we got to do to
have a successful pop-up shop you need
to have more than one person engaged
right so we got to contact someone who
might have some extra clothes that he's
maybe grown out of because he's a big
boy now he turned 21 and he's a big
bouncing baby boy that needs to be asked
for some clothes so when you got a big
bouncing book hello hi hey how's it
going
we're doing a pop-up shop and we're
hoping that you have some clothes that
you'd like to donate to the call oh you
do all perfect oh great we're gonna
clean them maybe I don't know okay all
right well we're right outside your
apartment
hello do I have clothes yeah mozzarella
sticks that have been there for a while
a little hard oh you may not do you want
a shower curtain
no yes yeah yeah yeah you have various
items if you want are you just gonna
give me extra room you can have this
what we used that could be a very
valuable item ah this is from the
Christmas clan 'we can't wait where you
play with that one hang out here for a
bit
[Music]
I'm Vaughn I literally only asked for
clothes do you want any Xbox one games
oh I don't know we don't need it just
ask for clothes now we have stuff you
want don't want already said no no oh
wait you could have more do you want a
poster poster of what I'll show you see
Jim hold on wait you forgot your got
your mod sticks no no
okay all right so we're engaged and
we're ready to go we need to move over
we need to clean this stuff we need to
filter out whatever Ethan got that is
garbage which a lot of it is stick to
the plan
we gotta make a pop-up shopping we got
to make it happen good pop you ready to
set up shop you ready to be an
entrepreneur launch day is always so
stressful what we need to do is we need
to get the the merchandise in a good
setup so that people can browse at their
leisure we've got my clothes
we've got Ethan's actual clothing
contributions in this bad boy here at
the Google shirt right there I think in
our rush we've forgot to wash the
clothes but I think people want that
Musk authentic dear man shirt or pants
flap classic flap I'm carrying less and
less sure and and then whatever Ethan
have in this bag what did he actually
give us
pants why why why did it give us bay
leaves sure sure sure but all that aside
we need to advertise when you look at
this what do you see
untapped potential the potential for
anything and most importantly the
potential for advertising
that's not legible at all that says
boutique's markiplier has been to the
boutique pretty good rap we need a logo
of course we need a logo that represents
infinite potential so an infinity sign
because there's good it's the the
clothing is both timeless and has so
many possibilities and you're always
moving forward yeah here take a picture
let's advertise this why didn't you tell
me that looks like a penis what a sweet
filter on that save that posted open for
business yeah
the customers are already rolling in
please browse our wares as you can see
I've got an assortment of lovely lovely
lovely merchandise over here oh hello
welcome to the boutique we a rejected
version of the new holographic team see
it has no holographic at all
that means it's one of a kind this will
never be made because it was a mistake
so the first sample will be free but
then you'll keep coming back for more
right you'll get addicted to the product
I see how it is there you go you're
welcome
are you around the store I'll hold chica
ok holographic ok yes yes yes uh 275 275
I got 30
you got 30 cents $35 yeah 5 5 5 5 5 5 5
you better not drive off not running a
free shop for sale we got it dress you
hold on to that money
alright alright alright what else we got
come on come on come on
does it come about $1 oh you want this
going for $1 $1 going for 1 100 101 Oh
Ansel alright 50 cents 50 cents
starting at 50 cents no dammit why
didn't we bring any change
ooh these are Java pants that were in
the deer man video the pants that I wore
yeah okay all right from the friend yoga
video this guy loves cats so much better
two-for-one combo $5 for both adorable
okay yes yes yes Ethan crank game plays
pants worn by a V man blue boy himself
perfect this is very very important to
me emotionally this is heartbreaking get
rid of even though I bought it at
Walmart for $5 a penny all right a
dollar I mean in my mind is worth a
thousand dollars but it's dollar Ethan
Esther shower curtain has probably
touched his naked body
all right fine whatever the ultimate
sale my reel all right wait wait wait
wait wait wait you guys add up getting
swept out by just this side thank you
all right I think we're officially sold
out you're too late we're sold out oh
but I know what you'd want
we're in a wow he sure day
guess whose shower curtain this is you
see those stains that's 100 percent
Ethan Nestor oh yeah I know run all
right yeah we're we're I sold out get
the [ __ ] out okay we're leaving that was
incredibly successful was our Hall how
much money did we make
Oh God we are rolling this is how I
build from the ground up you know it's
about how much work you put in you put
in work you get out reward that's how
you do it it also helps have amazing
fans who are willing to buy Ethan's
shower curtain which is a strange thing
but pretty cool so thanks so much for
your help
and thank you everybody to came out you
know it's a big shout out to them
they're awesome people in them so we're
happy to have them with us you know but
there'll be more adventures later on so
thanks again and as always seeing the
next one bye